翻訳: Kumika Moore
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さん こんにちは
石井美保です
宇宙から地球に
話題が降りてきますけれども
皆さん この会場は 今日は
博物館の中にありますけども
すでに博物館を回られた方は いますか？
あっ いないですね
私は人類学者として 皆さんに今日
ちょっと違う博物館の回り方を
おすすめしたいと思います
皆さんは普段 博物館を回る時は
展示に集中してると思うんですね
ですけれども 私がおすすめしたいのは
その展示の背後にある「しかけ」とか
「しくみ」に着眼するという風な見方ですね
とは言っても 実際にその展示の背後に
何か からくりがあるというんではなくて
どのように 配置されているとか
どのように 照明が落ちているとか
どんな風な順路で 進むように
誘導されてるかとかですね
そういうことをひっくるめて「しかけ」とか
「しくみ」という風に言えると思います
そうした「しかけ」とか「しくみ」というのは
普段は その展示物の背後に隠れてしまって
私たちにとっては あんまり
気付かないものですけれども
でも 実際には そうした
「しかけ」とか「しくみ」があることによって
私たちが その展示物と
どういう風に向き合うか
あるいは この館の中を
どういう風に動き回るかということが
方向付けられているわけですね
実は そうした
「しかけ」や「しくみ」というのは
私たちの日常生活の中にも
多くあるわけですね
その多くは 公共空間の中に
見て取ることができると思います
例えば 皆さんよく使われる駅ですけれども
日本ではですね
例えば 大阪なんかの都市では
エスカレーターの右側に人が立って
左側を急いでる人が上ったり下りたりする
という風なシステムになってると思うんですね
ところが 大阪以外の所に行くと
並ぶ方向が逆だったりするわけですね
私のように大阪で生まれ育って
初めて東京なんかに行くと
最初は 列に並ぶ方向を間違って
まごまごしたりするんですけども
だんだんと「あ 皆んなこっちに並んでるな」
という感じで
自分の行動を修正するようになるんですね
これは いわば「駅」という
公共空間において自然発生的に
かっこ付きですけれども 合理的な
「しくみ」が生まれていった例かと思います
つまり 動く階段であるところの
「エスカレーター」と
「急いでいる人」と
「それほど急いでいない人」っていう風な
「人」と「モノ」の組み合わせが
そういう風な「しくみ」を
勝手に作り出してるわけですね
誰が そうしろと
言ったわけでもないけれども
ですけれども一旦 そういう風な
「しくみ」ができてしまうと
それは その場所において ある種の
ルールですとかマナーみたいな形で
私たちの行動を 規制していくようになる
さらには 私たちがそれに
すっかり慣れてしまうと
まったく当たり前のこととして
見えなくなっていくわけですね
「透明化する」と
言ってもいいですけれども
ですけれども 一旦 もし私が例えば
体がちょっと不自由になったりして
今ある人とモノのスムーズな「しくみ」に
乗れなくなってしまった時に
今まで当たり前だと思っていた
そうした「しくみ」や「しかけ」が
実は そんなに当たり前の
ものじゃなかったという形で
姿を現してくることがあるわけですね
あるいは その人とモノが
作り出している「しくみ」なんですけれども
その人とモノの関係が
なんか ずれちゃった ―
上手くいかなくなった時にも
そういう「しくみ」が露わになる
ということがあるかと思います
人類学が どういう学問かというのは
諸説ありますけれども 私が思う一つには
私たちの日常生活の中で そうした
見えなくなっちゃってるような
「しくみ」や「しかけ」というものに
もう一度 光を当てて
それを引っ張り出すことによって
どういう風にそれが私たちの行動とか考え方を
方向付けたり 導いたりしているのか
ということを考えることですね
それを通して ある種の
世界の成り立ちみたいなものを
考え直すという学問だと言えます
言い換えると
透明化してしまったような
「しくみ」や論理みたいなものを
もう一度 不透明化する学問だと言えます
じゃあ どういう時に
そういう「しくみ」や「しかけ」が
ふと 不自然なものとして
露わになるかというと
さっきも言いましたように
人とモノの関係が 上手くいかなくなった時
あるいは すでにある「しくみ」に また別の
「しくみ」みたいなものが入ってきた時に
その間にコンフリクトが
起こったりすると思いますけれども
そうした時に「おかしいな」
「これは当たり前のものじゃなかった」
という風に
新しく その物事を捉え直すことが
できると思うんですね
今日は私が調査をしている
南インドのカルナータカ
マンガロールって この辺りですけれども
この事例を使って 皆さんに そうした例を
ちょっとご紹介したいと思います
皆さん この写真を見て
どういう風に感じられますかね？
ごく普通の外国の市街地のように
見えるかと思います
ですが
ところが ちょっと離れて見てみると
さっき示した写真というのは 実は
この山の上に そびえている
巨大な工業地帯の一部なんですね
その周りには こういう風に
深い森林が生い茂ってまして
その下の方に 農地があるわけです
これは「マンガロール経済特区」って
呼ばれている巨大な経済特区で
さっきのような農村地帯の真ん中に
突如として できてるんですけども
最新のテクノロジーを駆使して
石油化学関連の工業地帯ができています
多くは多国籍企業で
インド国内のみならず
世界中から一流のエンジニアたちが
集まってるわけですね
つまり こういう むき出しの大地と
テクノロジーと機械から成る世界ですね
それが「経済特区」と言えると思います
ところが それを取り巻いてるのは農村世界で
さっきの経済特区とは まったく違う
「しくみ」とか論理で
動いている世界なわけですね
その中でも面白いのは
ここで「ブータ」って―
「神霊」という風に書いてますけど
土地の神様の祭祀ですね
それをお祀りしています
そのブータっていうのが何かというと
その土地の神様とも言われてますし
この辺りにいる虎ですとか
猪とか蛇みたいな野生動物の霊ですね
「スピリット」とも言われてますし
あるいは その水田を取り巻いている野生の
自然の領域の力そのものだ
という風にも言われています
年に一度 この村の有力者の人たちが
おっきなお祭りを開きまして
この真ん中にいるのが
「憑坐（よりまし）」ですね
「スピリットミディアム」っていう風に
言いますけれども
その憑坐にブータが憑依してくる —
乗り移るわけですね
それを通して お告げを
告げたりするんですけれども
そうした憑坐に憑依したブータと
村の領主たちが
直接に やり取りをするわけですね
その祭りの中で
これは村の領主の
一番偉い人ですけども
彼がブータに 作物を供物して
それを受け取ったブータは その見返りに
来年も この村を祝福して
豊作を与えるという風に約束する
こうしたことが もうずっとですね
何十年も 何百年も行われてきた
という風に言われています
ところがですね
さっきも見ました経済特区っていうのは
基本的には そうした土地とか土地の神様に
依存したような世界ではなくて
農地とか山林を切り開いて更地にして
その上に こういう
近代的な工場を建てている
そこで働いている人たちも
そういう風な 農民とは違って
土地とか土地の神様に依存した
生活をしているわけではなくて
基本的には 賃労働に従事しているわけですね
こういう風に見てきますと
いわば その伝統的な農村世界の
それを作り出しているような
論理や「しくみ」が
近代的な論理や「しくみ」 —
近代合理的なそれへと変わっていって
一元化されていっている
そういう風に見えるかもしれません
ところが 現実は そんな風に
単純には進まなかったわけですね
この経済特区というのは 実際は
第一段階から第二段階を経て 第三段階まで
ものすごい規模で拡大することが
計画されてたんですね
農村をすべて壊していくような勢いで
ところが 2011年に 第二段階の途中で
この開発というのが止まってしまうんです
それはなぜか？
一つには その地域の
農民を中心とする人たちが
大規模な反開発運動を
行ったということがあります
彼らにとっては 農民ですので
土地を開発によって奪われて
他の地域に立ち退かされることは
まさに死活問題なわけですね
それだけじゃなくて
この土地というのは彼らにとって
さっき言いました ブータと呼ばれる
神様と深く結びついているわけなので
自分たちだけ そのブータを置いて
あるいは そのブータを
お祀りしている社を置いて
別の地域に行くっていうことは
許されないわけですね
彼らだけじゃなくって
社会運動家ですね —
アクティビストたちが
その彼らをサポートする中で
そうした「ブータを置いて私は行けません」
という彼らの論理を
これは 農民たちの
伝統文化なんだっていう形で
別の形に読み換えることで
メディアに紹介していくわけです
そうした形で反開発運動っていうのが本当に
大規模に盛り上がっていったことを
とうとう カルナータカ州も
無視できなくなって 州首相が2011年に
「もうこれ以上開発することは禁ずる」
という風な
命令を下すということに
なったわけです
それだけではなくて
さっき外観を見ていただいた
経済特区の工業プラントの中でも
実は変化が起こっていました
さっき申し上げました通り
経済特区というのは基本的には
近代テクノロジーと経済合理性と
それから機械と人の共同関係によって
動いているような世界ですね
その「しくみ」が
上手く回っている限りにおいては
そういう「しくみ」に ここで働いている
人たちが疑問を持つことはないわけですね
ところが この工業プラントの中では
非常に頻繁に
事故とか機械の不具合とか
そうした問題が起こっていたわけです
特に 2011年には
海外から来たエンジニア数名を含む
数人が死傷してしまうような大規模な
人身事故というのが起こってしまいました
こういう風に人と
人々が使っているモノとの関係性に
きしみが生じるような事態が起きた時に
この経済特区の幹部たちは
「今の個々の問題に 技術的な
対処をするだけでは無理だ」と
「何か この経済特区それ自体を動かしている
『しくみ』に問題があるんじゃないか」
という風な見方が出てくるわけですね
それで彼らが どうしたかというと
ここの写真に写っていますけれども
その外からですね
彼らは占星術師たちですけれども
占いをする人たちですね
彼らを呼んできて
この相次ぐ事故の背後にある
別の「しくみ」、別の論理みたいなものは
何かというのを明らかにしようとしたわけです
この占星術を まさに
ここは工業プラントの中で
これはオフィスの中で
こうやって儀礼をやってるんですけども
それを通して何が言われたかといいますと
その相次ぐ事故というのは
この経済特区を取り巻いている森林地帯ですね
そこの野生の力
つまりはブータの力ですけれども
それが引き起こしているんだ
ということが言われたわけですね
その野生の力と この経済特区との
関係を上手く調整するためには
この経済特区の中にブータの社を作って
お祀りしなさいという風なお告げが
占星術を通して告げられるわけです
それ聞いた企業幹部の人たちは
実際に こんな形で すごく立派な
ブータの社を建てて
そこで お祀りを始める
ということをするわけですね
先ほど見ましたように
農民たちにとっては そもそも
ブータの祭祀を通して
野生の領域とやり取りをして
その力を蓄えて
農耕に役立てるという風な
非常に農民的な世界というものが
いわば 自然なものとして
受け取られてきたわけです
ところが そこに「開発」というものが
入ってくることによって
今まで 言ってみれば 自然な論理として
受け取られていたブータの祭祀というのが
「彼らの伝統文化なんだ」という形で —
別の形で捉え直される
ということが起こるんですね
一方で じゃあ経済特区の方は
さっきも言いましたように
基本的にはテクノロジーと
経済合理性によって動いている —
あるいは 人と機械の親密な関係性の上で
成り立っているんですけれども
そこに 事故というものが起こって
その「しくみ」自体が疑問視された時に
今度 神霊祭祀という
まったく別の「しくみ」とか
論理というものが導入されてくる
そのことを通して
今まで非常に 強固なものだと
思われていたような
近代テクノロジーとか経済合理性という風な
「しくみ」とか「しかけ」そのものが
実はそれほど万能なものじゃなかった —
あるいは 野生の力の影響を受けるような
脆弱なものだったんじゃないかという風な
意識が人々の間に持たれるように
なってくるという風に言えます
これは言ってみれば
その「農村社会の『しくみ』とか論理」と
「経済特区の『しくみ』とか論理」という
相異なる「しくみ」や論理が
このマンガロールのある地域で出合って
非常に親密に絡み合うことを通して
それぞれが それぞれの世界で
自然なものとして透明化していたような
「しくみ」が そうではないものとして
別の形で捉え直された
そういう事例かな
という風に言えるかと思います
最初に申し上げましたように
私たちの身の回りというのは 実に様々な
明文化されてない 人とモノの
組み合わせから成るような
その「しくみ」とか「しかけ」によって
できているわけで
私たちは知らないうちに
それに従ったりとか
あるいは それを再生産したり
しているわけですね
ただ そういう「しくみ」とか
「しかけ」が自分にとって
それほど自然なものじゃない
ものとして現れてくる時というのは
人とモノの関係性が
上手くいかなくなった時ですね
例えば 私たちの身近で言えば
災害などが そうしたきっかけとして
あるかと思いますけれども
そうした究極的な事態ではなくても
ちょっと視点を変えてみて
さっきのエスカレーターの例ではないですけど
異邦人になったつもりで
世界を見てみると
まさに 今まで自分が自然なものとして
思っていた論理とか「しくみ」みたいなものが
当たり前じゃないものとして
見えてくるかなと思います
そういう風に 自分の視点をずらして
違うものとして世界を見てみることの利点は
「世界を多様化する」
という風なだけじゃなくって
自分自身の行動の選択肢を
増やしたりとかですね
あるいは ちょっとわざと
ずらしてみたりとか
そういう風な形で ある種自分自身を
柔軟にすることにも繋がると思います
さっき経済特区が こんな風に
どんどん 農村世界に
進出してくるかに見えたように
知らないうちに
ある「しくみ」とか「しかけ」みたいなものが
イメージ化されることなく
私たちの行動を一元化していっているような
契機というのは あると思うんですね
今の日本でも ひょとしたらそういうことが
いつの間にか起こってるかもしれない
私たちは その目に見えない「しくみ」に
いつの間にか従っているかもしれないわけです
ですけれども 神霊祭祀がそうだったように
一見 マイナーに見える論理とか「しくみ」
というものを ちょっと持ってくることで
それが相対化されて
そうじゃない世界の可能性 —
そうじゃない世界のあり方
みたいなものが
部分的にでも見えてくる可能性は
あるかと思います
人類学のやっぱり仕事というのは
そういう形で透明化している
見えない「しくみ」みたいなものを
一回 不透明にしてみることによって
世界の別の あり方の可能性を示す
ということじゃないかなと思います
ありがとうございました
（拍手）